donc ça c'est la lanterne tels qu'on les
a récupérés de la ville de paris sur la
place de la république
quant à l'été recettes ya trois ans
[Musique]
30 luminaires de 100 kg en bronze ont
retrouvé leur jeunesse ici sur les bords
de la creuse l'entreprise porte le nom
de son fondateur lenzin un immigré
italien
antoine bonneville a racheté il ya 13
ans cette usine de 25 salariés qui
fabriquent des éclairages de luxe pour
plus de 50 pays dans le monde
ce sont des luminaires qui sont plutôt
des luminaires aujourd'hui d'époque qui
vont être passées en peinture donc on
peut avoir toutes les nuances de
de l'arc en ciel
la première étape c'est de la poudre
mais sur la crosse vous voyez ici
la deuxième étape c'est la cuisson donc
l'acquisition ses 240 degrés et on
obtient une qualité de peinture
identique à celle de qu'on trouve dans
le domaine de l'automobile
un savoir faire de très haut niveau pour
lequel il est parfois difficile de
trouver de la main d'oeuvre dans cette
partie du berry en pleine
désertification le point qu'on a c'est
non pas de vendre nos produits sont les
vents dans d'autres régions dans
d'autres pays ces deux
d'avoir les bonnes compétences et me
faire venir car la tradition requiert de
la haute technologie comme cette
cintreuse numérique arrivés depuis moins
d'un an
c'est nettement plus en plus performants
copé devant on n'a plus besoin de
remplir de sable tous fait des tubes
vide et c'est en une seule fois
près de 70% de la production est
destinée aux collectivités publiques
comme ici sous le métro parisien
mais les réverbères d'argentan orne
aussi le pont alexandre iii ou bien les
abords de la mosquée de marrakech
c'est la reconnaissance d'un savoir
faire collectif de l'entreprise
historique
je dirais de tous les tous les
personnels notamment les personnes de
l'atelier
et puis c'est aussi une fierté de de
pouvoir dire qu'on fabrique en france
avec une certaine tradition sans bien
sûr rester dans le dans le passé il faut
penser aussi à notre avenir donc on
bâtit notre avenir en s'appuyant sur
nouveau compétences du passé le label
patrimoine vivant a été décerné parmi
les tout premiers en 2014 par emmanuel
macron alors ministre de l'économie